Ласкаво просимо до прискореного курсу про навчання в Німеччині.
Будь ласка, відкрийте сторінку 15 у ваших підручниках: "Основи".
"Hochschule" буквально означає "вища школа". Але це не схоже на американську "high school".
У Німеччині це загальний термін для закладів вищої освіти, включно з більш професійно орієнтованими
"Fachhochschulen" (фаховими вищими школами) та радше академічно орієнтованими "Університетами".
Першим університетом, який відкрив свої двері для викладання,
був Гейдельберзький університет ще в 1386 році. Нині ж є університети по всій Німеччині.
Наступний розділ: "Вступ до університету".
Деякі курси набирають студентів за системою "Numerus Clausus", коли їхня кількість обмежена.
Для допуску абітурієнти повинні мати певну мінімальну підсумкову оцінку в середній школі,
а іноді навіть складають вступні іспити.
На "Zulassungsfreie Studiengänge", тобто курси вільного допуску,
отримати місце може кожен, хто відповідає основним вимогам.
Звісно, це означає, що їм, можливо, доведеться сидіти у переповнених аудиторіях.
Популярні курси серед студенток у Німеччині - бізнес, право та психологія.
А серед студентів - бізнес, машинобудування та інформатика.
Протягом останнього десятиліття була спроба залучити більше жінок
до вивчення так званих предметів "MINT".
Це Математика, Інформатика, Науки природничі та Техніка.
І кількість жінок, які вступили на ці курси, за цей час зросла вдвічі.
Деякі курси, такі як медицина та викладання, передбачають наприкінці "державні іспити".
Їх приймає держава, а не університет.
Це зроблено для забезпечення високих стандартів в інтересах суспільства.
І, нарешті, сторінка 32: "Університетська система".
Раніше у Німеччині дотримувались системи дипломів, але в 1999 році болонський процес
дав поштовх по всій Європі для стандартизації якості вищої освіти.
Відтоді більшість німецьких університетів перейшла на систему бакалавр-магістр.
90% студентів-бакалаврів в академічних університетах продовжують далі вчитися на магістра.
Це частково можна пояснити наступним пунктом...
Мабуть, найкраще у навчанні в Німеччині? Вартість.
Навчання в приватному університеті може коштувати десятки тисяч євро,
але більшість німецьких вузів - державні, з нульовою платою за навчання.
Студенти мають сплатити лише "Semesterbeitrag". Це адміністративний внесок
приблизно від 100 до 350 євро за семестр.
Більше того, батьки продовжують отримувати виплати на дітей,
які навчаються на денній формі, до їхнього 25-ліття.
І на цьому пільги не закінчуються. Якщо ви студент у Німеччині,
ви отримаєте купу знижок у кафе та ресторанах, на телефонні контракти чи на проїзд.
При цьому їздити по регіону, де розміщений виш, можна абсолютно безкоштовно!
Тож багато хто записується на будь-який курс в університеті лише, щоб користуватись халявою.
Можливо, ви також чули про отримання "BAföG". Мені знадобилося багато часу,
щоб зрозуміти, що це, виявляється, абревіатура -
скорочення від Bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz.
Це закон, який регулює гранти і позики для студентів.
Близько 20 відсотків німецьких студентів отримують "BAföG".
Звичайно, студентам все одно доводиться платити за оренду житла, книги та їжу.
Близько чверті студентів у Німеччині проживають з батьками чи родичами,
ще чверть - у власній квартирі. 30 відсотків живуть у WG, що означає "Wohngemeinschaft".
Така собі комуналка, коли студенти разом мешкають в одній квартирі.
Більшість вузів також пропонують житло у "Wohnheime". Це такі гуртожитки
з невеликими приватними кімнатами та спільною кухнею.
Зазвичай це найекономніший варіанти, але потрібно подати заявку заздалегідь.
Німеччина - популярна серед іноземних студентів завдяки вартості,
репутації та дедалі більшій кількості курсів англійською мовою.
Здебільшого іноземні студенти також навчаються безкоштовно!
Німецькі вузи мають добру славу, і все ж вони, як правило, не потрапляють
у топи міжнародних рейтингів університетів.
Це може бути пов’язано з грошима, орієнтацією на навчання багатьох,
а не лише обраних, і тим фактом, що багато досліджень у Німеччині
проводяться у спеціалізованих науково-дослідних інститутах.
Навіть якщо ці інститути пов'язані з університетом, дослідження часто не враховуються.
Тож наскільки важливий науковий ступінь у Німеччині?
Цікаво, що майже 20% нинішніх членів Бундестагу його не мають.
Але у певних професіях це обов’язково, а в багатьох інших
це переважно сприятиме отриманню вищого доходу.
Звичайно, студентське життя  - це не тільки навчання.
Різні студентські організації та факультети завжди влаштовують вечірки.
Я думаю, що студентське життя в Німеччині ніби створено для вечірок!
Звичайно, зараз цього бракує через пандемію.
Універ - це перш за все місце, де зустрічаєшся з іншими людьми,
де зав'язуєш дружні стосунки, де вперше зустрічаєш людей
зі справді схожими інтересами.
В університеті можна почати доросле життя і вирішити, з ким ви хочете проводити час,
з ким випити кави після лекції.
На дозвіллі є багато справ, якими можна зайнятися - студентські товариства,
мистецтво, музика, читацькі клуби. Можна також стати політично активним.
Що порадиш тим, хто планує вступити до універу?
Цілком нормально нервувати! І не забувайте, що це щось нове для всіх.
Не поспішайте і знайдіть те, чим ви справді захоплені, те, що вас цікавить
і чому ви можете присвятити години, дні, місяці і навіть роки!
Не вивчайте щось лише тому, що це дає гарні перспективи для роботи
або тому що хтось із вашої родини вивчав це!
Якщо ваш гаманець і ваші батьки дозволяють, я б не надто засиджувався за навчанням,
а насолоджувався б студентським життям.
Якщо постаратися, це може бути одним із найкращих періодів у вашому житті.
Досить цікавим аспектом університетського життя в Німеччині
є "Verbindungen" або студентські братства.
Ці товариства володіють нерухомістю, і члени братства можуть
проживати там з дуже низькою орендою. Вони організовують заходи та лекції,
а деякі підтримують такі традиції як фехтування.
Членство у братстві фактично на все життя. Робиться соціальний і
фінансовий внесок в товариство і після закінчення університету.
Ці групи традиційно були лише чоловічими, елітарними та дуже консервативними.
Приблизно з 12 століття студенти по всій Європі об'єднувалися заради захисту та братання.
У Німеччині студенти з певних регіонів створили групи під назвою "Landsmannschaften",
які часто відрізнялися особливим кольором одягу.
Нині, за оцінками, менше 2 відсотків студентів є членами братств.
Є групи, які залишаються суто консервативними, а деяким навіть закидають правий екстремізм.
Але існують також і жіночі та змішані товариства.
Багато братств, хоча й не всі, відмовилися від дуельних ритуалів.
Дякую всім, хто надихнув на цю тему!
Якщо у вас є ще якісь пропозиції, пишіть у коментарях.